just because one person is comfortable
with their weapon doesn't mean that that
gives that person the right to infringe
on the rights of other people who aren't
comfortable if you're not in Waller
politics the Constitution is crystal
clear it's very simple the right to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed
unlike in most states in California it's
difficult to get a concealed carry
license this has led to the practice of
open carry in which some private
citizens carry holstered unloaded
weapons in plain sight and recently some
California politicians have been working
to make gun laws even more restrictive
you don't need a handgun to order a
cheeseburger
you don't need a handgun to get a cup of
coffee California Assemblyman Anthony
Portantino authored assembly bill 144
which would ban the practice of open
carry in California the open carry
situation wastes police resources it
creates a tense situation between the
law officer doing their job and the
Californian openly carrying their weapon
in fact open carry advocate Sam will
annek experience just such an encounter
occurring in November 2008 I was
carrying minding my own business and two
patrol cars pulled into the parking lot
officers proceeded to perform a 1203 one
to ensure that will annex gun was
unloaded in accordance with California
law what these guys decided to do was
pull their guns out and take me down to
the ground at gunpoint I was trying to
explain to them that open carry is legal
under California law that there is no
permit required they told me a couple of
times we don't care what the law is you
can't do that
well annex excessively pressed charges
against the San Diego PD for unlawful
arrest without reasonable suspicion this
incident led to a failed attempt by
Assemblymember Lori Saldana to ban open
carry back in 2010 so how do
California's gun laws compare the laws
in other states we have a system of may
issue concealed weapons permits which
translates into it
you haven't made a healthy contribution
to the sheriff's reelection fund you're
not getting a concealed weapon permit
it's cronyism and it's corrupt but
that's how it is
California unlike most states issues
concealed carry permits or CCWs under
may issue rules meaning that the choice
to issue is left up to the discretion of
the sheriff in each county as opposed to
the shall issue rule which allows anyone
who passes a basic background check and
skills test to obtain a weapon UCLA law
professor Eugene Bullock creator of the
popular law blog the Bullock conspiracy
says that the complex history of guns in
America has led to the strange situation
in California today starting with the
early 1800s many states enacted bans on
concealed carry of guts and the premise
of those bans is concealed carry a
dishonorable thing something that
criminals do because really good
upstanding citizens they carry their
guns out there on their hips where
everybody can see them in fact carrying
a fully loaded firearm openly was legal
in California until 1967 when Governor
Ronald Reagan signed the Mulford Act
which specifically targeted Black
Panthers who would patrol their
neighborhoods bearing loaded rifles and
now California is set to ban all forms
of open carry without at all modifying
its restrictive concealed carry permit a
process in California law you need a
license to carry a concealed weapon you
need a license go hunt you need a
license to drive a car
but you don't need a license to carry an
unloaded handgun in public as long as
it's unloaded and that's a loophole if
the law enforcement officials are saying
you person don't qualify for a CCW or
there's issues why I shouldn't give you
a CCW why we did then say to that same
person but carry your weapon anyway so
you're saying there are a number of
people in California who shouldn't be
carrying gun
and this is closing that loophole no I
I'm not saying I'm not being the person
who's deciding who should get a CCW or
not that's for the law enforcement
professionals to decide in California
law enforcement professionals have
decided to grant CCW use to 0.1% of the
population in the average shell issue
state that number is 2.9 percent or 29
times higher so is it true that open
carry is a dangerous loophole that needs
to be closed as of this moment there
have not been any deaths or injuries to
my knowledge to open carry but again
we're here to avoid the tragedy it is
pretty clear that the predictions that
well when you pass shall issue there'll
be blood in the streets because
everybody's going to get into gunfights
over every single felled fender bender
or even many fender benders those have
not really materialized despite the lack
of violence perpetrated by open carriers
or CCW holders politicians like
Portantino and Saldana believe
California's gun laws aren't strict
enough although the 2010 effort
resulting from all annex encounter with
the San Diego PD failed to pass the 2011
Arizona shooting has created new
opportunities for California's gun
control proponents gun control
proponents believe the wounding of a
congresswoman is a political game
changer the fact that it's personal one
of their own I think is going to make a
dish
Jared Lochner had a smaller capacity
ammunition clip when he went to Gabby
Giffords event in Tucson what's happened
is since the events in Arizona gun
issues have taken on a greater national
debate and a greater significance what
that incident has brought to light is
there are very real threats out there
and there's a role for law enforcement
there's a role for good judgment and I
think it makes the case for a be 144
let's not have a proliferation of
weapons on Main Street I'm pretty
certain it's illegal to shoot Congress
people in the head it's illegal to
illegally conceal a weapon on your way
to commit a crime it's illegal to own a
gun with the intent of committing a
crime so we got this
at least three felonies already how many
more is it going to take to make him
stop the answer is it doesn't matter if
you stacked up fifty thousand felonies
you're not going to stop a crazy person
from doing crazy things it doesn't make
much sense to come up with comprehensive
law that that is aimed at focusing on
those very rare incidents as opposed to
the literally thousands of times more
common ordinary gun homicides in fact
crime rates have been falling since the
early 90s
despite indications from federal
background check requests that gun
ownership has been steadily increasing
if you're not in law or politics the
Constitution is crystal clear it's very
simple the right to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed keep and bear own
carry in case of confrontation handgun
it's it's very simple the Second
Amendment of the Constitution allows
people to defend their private property
and that includes your person right that
includes your person but when you're out
in Main Street California we've also
have sworn officers who are there to
serve and protect the public having your
gun on your hip walking down Main Street
is something from a western movie we
don't think of Main Street California or
the mall in the same way and to try to
make it be the same way again I think is
going back in time not forward in time
porch and Tina's office expects a be 144
to pass through the state Senate in late
July 2011 and beyond Governor Jerry
Brown's desk
by early August
you